ميدانيا تشهد مقاطعه زابولوجيا تبادلا
للقصف بين الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني فقد
اكد المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
كوفاليفا استمرار شني قواتي بلاده هجمات
ضد القوات الروسيه في المناطق القريبه من
منطقتين
وبيرديانس في مقاطعه زابولوجيا جنوبي
اوكرانيا
في اربع بلدات جنوبولوجيا
تواصل قوه الدفاع الاوكرانيه
هجوميه في بلدات باتجاهات
وقد حققت نجاحا جزئيا في عده بلدات وهي
مناطق محصنه عند الحدود التي تم الوصول
اليها والحقت المدفعيه اضرارا باهداف
العدو الذي يركز جهوده على الدفاع ومنع
تقدم قواتنا في اتجاه اوريخيف
لم يتاخر حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بان ان
انفجارات دوت في منطقه زاكولوجيا جنوب
شرقي اوكرانيا واوضح مراسلنا ان ذلك ياتي
بعد اطلاق القوات الروسيه صواريخ من طراز
اس 300
انتقل الى زبولوجيا مع حسان مسعود
زبولوجيا المحاور هناك الاكثر اشتعالا لكن
تسلط الاضواء الان على محطه زابولوجيا
النوويه ما الذي يحصل وماذا عن التصريحات
الاوكرانيه بشان تسرب اشعاعي محتمل
ما يحصل حسن وما يجري الحديث عنه خطير
للغايه على اقل تقدير نظرا لحديث نائب او
وزير الداخليه قبل قليل عن ان اوكرانيا
تحضر بشكل جدي لمثل هذه الاحداث وهو يشير
بذلك الى ما قال انها استفزازات روسيه
يمكن ان تحدث في محطه النوويه يمكن ان
تؤثر على
الاشعاع النووي وان ينتشر الاشعاع النووي
لمده يوم واحد في محيط هذه المنطقه دون
الاشاره الى اي مدى يمكن ان يصل هذا
الاشعاع وان هذا الاشعاع بعد يوم سينخفض
الى 80 او بنسبه 80% ولكن هو يتحدث عن
تفاصيل هذا الامر هذا يشير الى ان الحديث
عن
حدوث امر ما في محطه النوويه يمكن ان في
اي وقت خلال الفتره القادمه وهذا الامر
جاء على لسان كبار المسؤولين في اوكرانيا
على لسان الرئيس الاوكراني وعلى ايضا لسان
وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه التي ايضا
ارسلت بيانا تحذر فيه من هذا الحدث كما
ايضا جاء اليوم على لسان وزير الداخليه
على سبيل الاجراءات العمليه يشير الى
عمليات اجلاء يمكن ان تحدث ايضا للمواطنين
والسكان في منطقه زابوروجيا يشير كذلك الى
الاجراءات التي على المواطنين ان يقوموا
بها في حال حدث مثل مثل هذا الامر وهذا
كله يربطه المسؤولون الاوكرانيون بما حدث
ايضا بصدق خوفكا هم كانوا يشيرون الى مثل
هذا الحدث الذي يمكن ان يتم تنفيذه في تلك
المحطه وبالفعل بعد ايام او اسابيع من
الحديث بشكل جدي عن مثل هذا الاحتمال جرى
بالفعل تفجير محطه كخوفكال بطبيعه الحال
الجانب الاوكراني يتهم الجانب الروسي بهذا
الامر الا ان ايضا هناك تبادل التهامات
هذا ايضا يشير الى ان ما يجري الحديث عنه
هنا في محطه النوويه هو امر خطير للغايه
ونحن سنتابع خلال الايام القادمه اي
تفاصيل بهذا الامر ولكن هذا المعطى لا
ينفصل عن المعطى الميداني وهو ما يجري على
جبهه جبهه تحديدا المنطقه الجنوبيه التي
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها تحاول التقدم
عند اكثر من منطقه باتجاه مناطق بعيده حتى
هذه اللحظه وهي منطقه او منطقه تبريديانسك
عن خط المواجهه تقول ان التقدم هو حتى
كيلو متر واحد فقط وان التقدم عند هذه
الجبهه هو بالامطار عندما كنا خلال اليوم
الماضي هناك تابعنا ذلك على ارض الواقع
يقولون ان القوات الروسيه
حصنت هذه المنطقه
بخنادق وكذلك
الغام وهذا هو الواقع عند الجبهه وهذا
يتزامن مع القصف المتواصل شكرا جزيلا لك
حسان مسعود من زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره